[dramatic music]
Bladesmiths, congratulations.
You've made it to the final
round of this competition.
Now it's time for you
to go back to your home
forges and recreate this
iconic weapon from history--
a Bhuj.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
[inaudible].
Good luck to you, buddy.
[rock music]
BENTON: So it's day one.
I'm back home in
Evansville, Indiana,
and I'm ready to get
started on this Bhuj build.
I'm working on the dagger first.
I think it's the easiest thing
to warm up and start with.
I really got to
watch my dimensions.
This dagger, as
I'm forging it, I'm
keeping in mind that where
the ricasso and the transition
from the blade to
the tang is, I got
to make sure I'm
not too wide to go
inside the handle and the pipe.
I got to make sure
I'm not too narrow
or this thing's going
to rattle around.
So I really have a tight
window that I need to fit in.
Good enough for now.
I made some great progress,
but I've got a lot to do.
It's freaking me out.
JOE: It's day one.
I'm here at the home forge.
Get warm in here,
man-- it's freezing.
I'm making a Bhuj.
It's a little bit boujie, I
would say-- a little bourgeois.
It's not only a
piece for warfare,
but it's a really
artistic expression
of whoever's carrying it.
I'm thinking of
doing some san mai,
so sandwiching it
with a mild steel.
That'll just make it
that much more tough.
I chose san mai to really
bring the most out of these two
different types of steels.
The mild steel is very tough.
It can take a lot of
bending without cracking,
while the hardened
51/60 in the center
is just coming down where
I need it along the edge.
Just need to get the billet
down to a more manageable size.
I hot cut off the excess.
And as I'm hot cutting, I'm
putting a lot of stresses
on those welds.
And one of the pieces of mild
steel's wanting to kind of rip
away.
That's pretty bad news.
From hot cutting it,
all the stresses on it
found a weak point right there.
So in order to fix
that delamination,
I got a few more tries at forge
welding it up to the thickness
that I have.
If I get too thin,
then it's a lost cause.
I just hope I can
make this work.
Not only is it day two, but
it is also my 28th birthday.
Creating a challenge
weapon in my home shop,
that's a pretty cool
birthday present.
Today, I'm going
to start forging
the larger blade of the Bhuj.
So what I'm trying to do is
split this tang off of here,
and I got to form my clip point.
Then I can draw my length out,
and that shape will follow.
And then I can start
getting that swoop
that I need for that Bhuj look.
Time to get this
bad boy quenched.
This is the moment that
I really need to nail,
and I am praying that this
thing's going to stay straight.
I pull it out.
[laughing]
Ah, that thing's harder
than $9 worth of jawbreakers
and straight as an arrow, man--
pretty good birthday.
JOE: It's day two, and
I'm looking at the blade.
And I'm not 100% on the
laminations on the san mai.
So it's seeming to make
the best sense just
to scrap it and start over.
I'm going to use a big
old piece of leaf spring
and see what I can do
a second time around.
Starting over with a
51/60 mono-steel blade,
time is really at a premium.
I may not finish.
So it's the
start of day three.
I have to start putting a
lot of puzzle pieces together
and do a lot of fabrication.
60's too hard.
So I think I need to
temper this some more.
A little hard for my liking for
what it's going to be doing,
so I'll soften it some more.
I'm trying to make sure that
my blade gets up to temperature
and [inaudible]
stress, so that way
I've got a nice flexible
yet strong blade.
If I don't get these blades
softened and more flexible,
they're more likely to snap.
Right now they're very brittle.
If I heat up the very end
and keep heating up the end,
the heat will travel and draw
the temper all the way down.
That's the best I
can do right now.
I've got my dagger tempered,
so I can put my handle on.
Then I'll slide my socket
on, weld that beast up,
and we're ready to go.
It fits right in there.
My blade is
completely assembled.
It's not pretty, but
it would perform.
I think it's ready to roll, man.
JOE: So yesterday I forged
out the blade of my Bhuj.
I forged out the stiletto, and
I got around to heat-treating
the Bhuj blade.
Today I have to
heat-treat the stiletto.
Heat-treating a
stiletto is going
to be a little tricky because
there's zero room for warpage.
So this thing needs to
be dead straight to be
able to fit in that handle.
If it's not, I mean, it
could hang up in there,
or might not even come out, or
just rub against interior wall
and dull the blade.
So it's the moment of truth.
Yeah, it looks great.
It looks perfectly straight.
It's time to start chiseling
in the elephant head
into the bolster now.
I'm choosing to put
an elephant on my Bhuj
because that was the
traditional creature
they would add onto it.
And I'd really like
to honor the culture
and these amazing smiths
for creating this.
There we go.
So the weapon as a whole I think
is becoming a beautiful piece.
Joe, Benton, welcome
back to the forge.
You fellas have had four
days at your home forges
to work on your Bhuj with
hidden stiletto blade.
Joe, how did it go?
It went well.
My blade's made
out of leaf spring,
got a coil-spring stiletto, and
some etch design work on there.
What about you, Benton?
I feel like my
build went well.
My blade's out of 51/60,
and my stiletto is 10/84.
It was a tough build, but
I feel great about it.
Well, gentlemen, only one of
you can be the "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And to determine which
one of you it will be,
it's time to test them.
It will be a strength test, a
sharpness test, and, up first,
the kill test.
Doug.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your Bhujes look beautiful,
but are they deadly?
Well, to find that out,
I will take your weapon
and deliver killing
blows onto pig carcasses.
Joe, you're up first.
Ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
JOE: My heart's racing.
My knees are rattling.
I just feel like
anything can happen.
[rock music]
Nice.
Oh, man.
[sigh]
First up, this blade is sharp.
The point is easy enough
to get into the carcass
and smash on the way out.
It's got a great feel
to it, nice stiletto.
There's even a handle
that you put on this,
so it gets a nice look to it.
Overall, sir, this
Bhuj will kill.
Thanks, Doug.
All right, Benton, are
you ready to ham it up?
Ready to rock and roll.
Let's do this.
BENTON: Joe's Bhuj
performed incredibly.
It split that pig in half.
And now it's my turn,
and I'm terrified.
I've never made this
style of weapon before.
I've never been able to test
this kind of construction.
I just don't know how
it's going to hold up.
[rock music]
Oh, [bleep], man.
Sorry, man.
It's a big piece of shrapnel.
[bleep] damn it.
Well, Benton, one of the
things I like about this,
you put on the leather.
It gave me a very nice area
to hold onto, and it's ovoid.
I can tell where the edge is.
But the obvious happened.
It's a coarse-grain
structure here.
I should have normalized that
tang much better than I did.
But when you're grinding
away long days in the shop
during this challenge
and you're just
focused on the finish line, it's
easy to overlook some things.
And obviously I did.
Well, Ben, any warrior
knows that if you
leave a piece of shrapnel that
big in a target, it's deadly.
However, a warrior also
knows that his weapon
needs to be strong.
And your blade has suffered
a catastrophic failure
in our very first test.
And therefore, you cannot move
forward in this competition.
Come on, brother--
did a great job, man.
[inaudible].
I feel pretty bummed.
But this challenge has been both
very difficult and invigorating
at the same time.
I've made things that
I've never made before,
and I've overcome some
challenges that I've
never had to face before.
So overall, it was
a great experience.
Joe, your blade is
sharp, deadly, and strong.
And you are the new
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]
How do you feel right now?
It's a little surreal.
I'm a "Forged in Fire" champion.
I won.
But you know, it
would've been nice to win
after the three tests.
But this has been a
totally unique opportunity.
It's really a big
affirmation of my abilities.
It's amazing.